I've said before and they were well
there's more than three but I just
thought of three last night while I was
preparing for today and there are at
least three reasons why we actually care
about polynomial division not just
because now hooray we can do it do you
feel like hey you can do it by the way
it's all right the negatives do sort of
send you for a spin the first time but I
promise you we'll get used to that as
you go through and you will but apart
from that just because we can why do we
care about this well here's my first
reason I said before if you want to
understand what an object is doing often
what you'll do is manipulate it in some
way and it turns out that polynomial
division is a great way to get in to
what's going on with any kinds of
polynomials we get given for example
I've given you a pair of cubics here
right these two cubic equations can you
do for me can you trace out with your
hand in the air what's like the general
shape when you graph a cubic function
what does it look like can you do it in
here yeah well your hand yeah okay all
right good you did a couple of loops
there right so it's going to be
something like this
generally speaking right now it happens
that I know this guy up here is going to
have three roots it's going to intersect
with the x-axis three times like so okay
but I can just as equally work out that
this guy without even graphing it we're
not going anywhere near that I can work
out that this only touches the axis once
it does this now how did I work that out
and the answer is if I go through
polynomial division with either of these
right you will find that this guy up
here it very nicely neatly breaks up
into one two three factors and from each
of those factors you get the one two
three roots you're like cool I can find
them I can locate them off I go in I
graph right but if you're trying to the
same exercise with this if you go
through the division what you'll find is
it divides nicely neatly rather once and
then at the other end here you get this
weird quadratic and this quadratic does
not neatly factorize right it's one of
those awkward ones you like to kind of
think of a number don't want to complete
the square I'll give it quadratic
formula and then it spits out at you
sorry no real solutions right now what
that's saying is you'll get a solution
here one this one here and then you get
no real solutions out of the rest of the
equation so we gain insight into what's
going
his polynomials doing in how it behaves
by performing polynomial division okay
there's the first thing the second thing
is integration we know how to do some
integration now right
we know how for example to integrate
this this is pretty much as easy as it
gets right but if I asked you to
integrate this guy up here you'd say Oh
gross I don't know where to begin right
well now that you know polynomial
division you're not all the way there
but your part the way there because if I
said well the integral of this what I do
with that right do you all agree
remember we just said this is an easy
thing to integrate here right like sorry
integral of this DX that would be easy
to deal with
okay well see this equation here if I
integrate at the left hand side it
stands to reason it would be the same
thing if I also integrated the right
hand side do you agree with that is that
okay it's an equation do something to
the left also do it to the right okay
well I'm also gonna divide by this if I
do it to the left I will also do it to
the right okay
yes Chloe oh no no really
oh boo how sad never mind you oh okay
yeah that's a bit sneaky so you kind of
sort of yeah okay that's all right I'm
gonna do the next bit anyway I have a
look at this guy here right and this is
Daniel Vettori before how would you
actually do the division well what's
nice about this is because I now have
some common factors namely this guy in
this guy right there's some canceling
that can happen here right there's a
little bit of canceling what color
should I choose no I'm gonna stick with
this guy right I'm gonna leave that big
integral sign there X minus 7x plus 2
divided by X plus 2 what will cancel the
X plus 2 is right so you're going to get
left with that guy right what you get
over here is well it's a bit awkward it
looks a liquid anyway now what's great
about this is when you do get to such a
point is you can integrate this guy
totally behaves this guy I can find the
primitive of X you can tell me a period
of X right x squared on two very good
you can tell me the primitive of neg
seven it's minus 7x right now this guy
you want to learn until next year but
you can totally integrate it turns out
well I don't spoil it too much yeah I'll
leave it it's a fun object that you
might not expect but it's actually one
you've been dealing with for a long time
several years so integration right when
you look at some things you're like I
don't know I don't know what to do with
this right but so much of your
mathematical career has been taking
problems that are insoluble right
they're like don't know what to do with
this but if I can transform it in some
way and keep all the objects the same
but it just looks a little bit different
I can turn it into a problem that
actually I can handle that ends up being
quite simple okay all right now what's
the last thing algebra right of which
polynomials is just like a you know a
further along version of developed right
the whole point of algebra isn't you can
deal with numbers and you can interact
with them and understand them even when
you don't know if their value is let me
just say that again because maybe you
like you guys generally are so good
enough with the machinery of algebra
that perhaps you never wondered why is
this matter right we deal with numbers
that we don't know their value all the
time and we can still work with them we
can still understand them and use them
to solve problems okay now I'd like you
to do this with me I'm get your
calculator out anything that you can
just do some multiplication division
with and I want you to think of a number
any number that you'd like I'm not going
to put any boundaries on it except can
you make it a positive integer because
we didn't do some division in a second
and okay if you pick some if you pick PI
you're gonna have a bad time in a second
okay so pick a positive integer of any
kind you can make a beak or you can make
it small it's up to you your number that
you've just said for yourself and please
by the way make sure you pick something
different to the person next to you
because this will be boring if you both
have the same thing okay pick your
number and then for said number I'd like
you to work out an easy thing and a bit
of a harder thing I want you to work out
what x plus 1 will be if your number is
X right just add 1 to it you're like I
don't need a calculator for that and
then write that down for example if your
number is 581 then X plus 1 will be 582
that was not hard okay this next bit is
why I asked you to get a calculator out
okay I'm looking expect you to work out
what 581 squared plus 5 volts so 581
plus 7 is
but whatever your number happens to be
can you please square it and then add
five lots of the same number and then
add seven okay and you should get
something where at the end and in fact
I'm gonna go work out what mine is is
your calculator Donna fit okay make it
smaller just so you calculate you can
deal with it
581 did you go into did you go to
scientific notation well done
what an overachiever okay okay so this
is what I've got right now presumably
you have do different numbers right
unless anyone else thought of 581 no one
else did right cool happy times right we
only had all of the numbers in the
universities job so hopefully you chose
a different okay now here's what I want
you to do I would like you to and you
can I'm not going to put limitations on
how you do it there's gonna be an easy
way and a hard way I would like you
please to divide your bigger number
right this second result
can you please divide it by the first
one and then tell me the remainder
actually it so happens like I was
alluding to before in this particular
case the remainder is the only thing I'm
interested in now just go ahead and do
that but keep it secret from the person
you're working it out next to you okay
so go ahead do the division work out
your remainder please
BAM that's how we come to morning class
four right for amazing insights like
that can you raise your hand for me if
you've done the division and have a
remainder don't tell me what it is just
tell me if you've got a remainder yep
okay I'm still waiting on a couple more
put your hand down thank you some people
at the back shows really ridiculous huge
numbers that's okay yes yes so you're
dividing this by this right yeah you got
that so 23 is the question right that's
the question I want the remainder yes
[Music]
I need my thing okay now I wonder if we
can do this together right hopefully at
this point even if not everyone
most people have found out there
remainded by now right on the count of
three I'm gonna ask Azure to say it out
loud your individual remainder okay are
you ready count of three three two one
miss Jacobs confused that's okay that's
interesting you all got the same
remainder I did
I got a remainder of three at least you
did get the same remainder if you
perform your division correctly okay by
the way you might have also noticed if
you went through that you might have
notice your question was also exactly
for bigger than what you divided by did
you notice that right now how did I know
that how did I know we would all come up
with this and the answer is when you
divide x plus x squared plus 5x plus 7
by X plus 1 if you do this polynomial
division ok then the question that you
get at the end let's call it Q of X
right all of you if you give this a go
we'll get a question of X plus 4 right
for bigger than the number you started
with and you will all find a remainder
of 3 right now what's brilliant about
this is if you have a go at this guy
here okay do this division as a
polynomial okay I will leave this as an
exercise to the reader if you do the
division it will take about I rubbed it
all off but it will take about three
sets of going through that divide
multiply subtract carry then divide
multiply subtract carry it'll do it
about three lots of that okay but if you
were really adventurous and you chose
some ridiculously huge number right if
you did the numerical division the
problem gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and more like brain numbing the
bigger the number is that makes sense so
just take longer and longer to divide
right but this guy always stays as
simple to divide as just these nice
simple single-digit whole numbers okay
see
I'm trying illustrate for you that
algebra usually the superpower to see
understand all these different objects
even when I don't even know what any of
your numbers were I didn't choose them
you chose them and I didn't even ask you
to tell me but I can still through
algebra right that's the whole point of
it I can know there is a pattern going
on underneath through polynomial
division just like every other technique
you've learned okay so I'm going to hit
pause there if you haven't already open
up your textbooks but it does anyone
have any questions any step here that
was a bit weird and confusing that they
want clarification on how do you do
you're talking about with numbers right
is that what you asked me for okay so
you're talking about this part like this
part here okay so for those of you who
are like how do I do this in my
calculator it doesn't just give me a
question and remainder the cheap and
easy way is like so okay if you do this
if you put this into your calculator
right my calculator will tell me that
the answer is five hundred and eighty
five points some weird stuff that I
don't know okay now this 505 here the
whole number that's the question that's
how ever many whole lots of your divisor
you can fit in there
right and then this guy over here what
it represents is your remainder right
that's the leftover it's not a whole lot
of your divisor it's a it's a part of
your divisor okay so the way to work out
okay well what is the leftover is you
can reverse engineer this usually using
the statement that we showed you before
right you can say okay three thirty
three hundred forty thousand four
hundred and seventy three right it's
going to be equal to five hundred eighty
five I got that from the calculator
display multiplied by five eighty one I
got that that's my original divisor that
I chose plus some other stuff right well
if you want to find out what some other
stuff is use algebra again you're like I
don't know what it is let's just give it
a name like our four remainder and then
if I want to solve for our what do I do
I just
I just I just subtract from both sides
right whatever this guy is right if I
subtract that from both sides I will
just be left with R on the right-hand
side are you content with that right one
of the things that's really wonderful
here is at least I don't remember ever
being taught that when I was in you
seven or even if you were taught that
you probably forgot but this is all
simple arithmetic you actually do know
it's just can you bend your brain into
the right shape to use all that existing
knowledge in a bit of an unusual
unfamiliar way